[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja herzlich willkommen hochwertiges
Publikum ich freue mich sehr dass sie
sie heute hier in der Hochburg begrüßen
darf ja wie soll man sagen zu einem
lauen spät Winterabend zu unseren
traditionellen
Frühlingskonzert der Garde Musik des
österreichischen Bundesheeres drei Jahre
konnten wir nicht Pandemie sie wissen es
aber wenn ich runter schaue lauter
begeisterte Augen lauter freundliche ich
weiß das ist nicht wegen mir sondern das
ist wegen der Damen und Herren hinter
mir die hier sitzen die schon sehr
gespannt und sehr mit großer Freude auf
Sie und Ihre Reaktionen warten wir
freuen uns auch ganz besonders dass
heute eher da ist nämlich der
Oberkommandierende der österreichischen
Armee unser Bundespräsident Dr Alexander
van der Bellen es ist schön dass Sie da
sind der Bundes
hinter einem erfolgreichen Mann steht in
meiner erfolgreiche Frau liebe Frau
Schmieder ebenfalls schön dass ihr heute
Abend hier in der Hofburg mit dabei sind
Doris Schmida
und nur in wenigen Ländern kann man
sagen dass die Geschicke der
Landesverteidigung in Frauenhand sind in
Österreich kann man es sagen guten Abend
der Bundesminister für Verteidigung
Magister Claudia Tanner schön dass sie
heute Abend da sind
[Applaus]
was sie vorhin gehört haben meine Damen
und Herren war der Alexander van der
Bellen Marsch der Herr Bundespräsident
hat es erkannt ihm zu Ehren gibt es auch
ein Rot Weiß rotes Karton der wird oder
wie bitte das habe ich noch nie gesehen
ein Rot Weiß Rot dabei ist das das ist
wirklich Liebe und sie wissen dieser
Mann trägt eigentlich beim Militär die
das Kürzel mm nicht für Musik naja
sondern für militärische Mozart er ist
es mehr oder weniger er komponiert auch
sehr vielen er hat auch diesen
wunderbaren van der Bellen Marsch
komponiert ja das ist schön
das ist schon meine gelungene
Überleitung zu meinem ersten
Gesprächspartner sehr geehrte
Bundespräsident ich konnte sie ja leider
heuer beim Wiener Opernball nicht
verarzten wie wir wissen aber wenn ich
das so sagen darf sie entgehen meiner
Liebe nicht ich darf heute ein Gespräch
mit Ihnen führen wir haben eine Pandemie
in der wir noch immer sind drei Jahre
lang wir haben einen so furchtbaren
Krieg auf europäischen Territorium den
wir uns nie vorgestellt haben wir haben
in österreichisches Bundesheer das seit
Jahrzehnten beweisen kann mit aller
Kraft und Stärke bei Naturkatastrophen
einzuschreiten sie Auftrag der Feinden
Nationen ist unsere Armee auch um
Frieden bemüht dieses letzte Jahr dieser
unfassbare Krieg zeigt dass wir auch
eine Landesverteidigung brauchen glauben
sie dass im Kopf der Österreicher auch
sein Umdenken ist langsam dass wir
unsere Bundesheer Soldatinnen und
Soldaten nicht nur bei Lawinen haben
werden es Schutz sondern auch wenn es
wirklich eine brennt
ich glaube Sie haben Recht dass
bis vor relativ kurzer Zeit das
Bundesheer hochgeschätzt wurde bei
Naturkatastrophen bei Lawinenabgängen
beispielsweise und und ähnlichem aber
das der Gesichtspunkt der militärischen
Landesverteidigung sozusagen irgendwo
sanft entsprungen ist also seitlich
Bundespräsident bin habe ich mich sehr
bemüht immer wieder auf die Budget
Sorgen des Bundesheers hinzuweisen und
das ist so einfach nicht weitergeht
diese Jahre wenn ich jahrzehntelange
Aushungerung
budgetäre außer um das Bundesheers jetzt
bin ich
was hätte ich gesagt froh man kann über
den Krieg in der Ukraine nicht froh sein
selbstverständlich es hat aber doch
wesentlich dazu beigetragen zusammen mit
anderen Dingen wesentlich beizuwerden
beizutragen dass dem der Gedanke der
militärischen Landesverteidigung wieder
ernst genommen wird und der jahrelange
Investition zurück Zuschauer beim
Bundesheer was die Ausrüstung betrifft
was Waffen betrifft was die
Skiausrüstung betrifft und was nicht
alles dazu kommt jetzt endlich einem
Umdenken gewichen ist beim hereingehen
habe ich mir noch gedacht wie lange ist
das her das in Österreich ernsthaft über
die Abschaffung der Musikkapellen beim
Bundesheer ernsthaft ernsthaft
diskutiert worden ist ja das heute Gott
sei Dank
unvorstellbar aber auch auf
militärischen Gebiets immer mittlerweile
wieder auf guten Weg Herr
Bundespräsident man darf einem
Staatsoberhaupt keine private Frage
stellen ich tue es trotzdem man weiß das
sind ihre Amtsführung eine
Ausnahmeerscheinung sind sie haben immer
mit dem gewissen Augenzwinkern egal was
sie machen mit einem mehr oder weniger
schlafwandlerischen Sicherheit schon
angelobungen zum Beispiel sie haben auch
bei den Reden zur Nation oder bei einem
öffentlichen Auftritten immer sehr viel
Humor dabei sie lassen sich sogar oder
sie müssen sich sogar beleidigen lassen
ohne zu reagieren um es nicht noch
schlimmer zu machen woher nehmen sie die
Kraft für all diese Dinge
merken sie wieso ich wird
es ist nicht so dass ich mich nicht
manchmal ärgern kann oder sogar wenn wir
niemand zuschaut einen Wutausbruch haben
kann aber es ist gut dass nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit zu machen glaube ich also
speziell in meiner Rolle
meine Frau und ich durch Schmieder und
ich besprechen oft erst später am Abend
leider später am Abend was noch alles
passiert ist und was noch passieren
könnte also es ist nicht so dass man
allein ist und mein Büro die
Präsidentschaftskanzlei hatte
ausgezeichnete Leute ohne das wäre ich
natürlich auch verlorenen Posten aber
danke dass Sie das so sehen
Gelassenheit in meiner Rolle aber auch
Gelassenheit in der Rolle der Frau
Bundesministerin glaube ich es gehört
zum Abend danke für dieses Interview
meine Damen und Herren ich glaube die
auch das steht mir nicht zu wir sind
sehr froh dass wir sie haben in
Österreich
danke schön Bruder
es heißt ja das große Konzert des
Frühlings zwei Namen meine Damen und
Herren sind
verbindbar mit Laune Qualität schönen
Frauen Franz Lehar und Robert Stolz das
sind zwei Namen die seit Jahrzehnten
begeistern
wir starten heute mit der Operette
Wiener Frauen das ist eine der eher
weniger bekannten Operetten von Franz
leer und dann gefolgt mit du sollst der
Kaiser meiner Seele sein von Robert
Stolz als genanntenistin hören wir Julia
wiesenjewski jetzt zuerst einmal die
obertüreste Operette Wiener Frauen von
Franz Lehar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich weiß eine Reichweite
Liebe
[Musik]
du sollst der Kaiser meine
Ohren du sollst den Boden ganz
[Musik]
trifft auf dich du
Träume gehen
[Musik]
schalte folgenden vor
hin meinen
Mann
sie ist
der Königin
[Musik]
meine Freunde
dem
Tod
das heißt siebten
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank Julia
ein äußerst großes das ist fertig
gefährlich hier sehr Wahnsinn die Stirn
sie erinnert mich irgendwie am ORF
stürzen
die junge Dame hat bereits große
Auftritte gehabt Vorsicht
sie hat in Graz Linz und Wien studiert
und erst vor einem Jahr hat sie ihren
Master gemacht ich glaube die junge Dame
wird eine große Karriere machen eine
große Karriere hat schon der Mann hinter
mir gemacht meine Damen und Herren
nämlich seit 2001 führt er als
musikalische Leiter und Kommandant und
Hauptverantwortliche aller neuen
militärmusiks dieses Orchester Herr
Professor Magister Bernhard her
Herr Magister
seit 2001 kann man kann man da
abschätzen wie viele Konzerte
wir sind bei tut und das ist auch sagen
das müssen wir mal vorher sagen
wenn es wirklich so ist das war beim
bundesweiten Fischer immer so der
ununterbrochen gesagt hat und vergessen
Sie ohne dass ein Sieger er war immer
der erste gesagt hat uns alles Gute
heute es war so lustig an hast du eine
Ahnung wie viele Konzerte du überhaupt
dirigiert hast kann man das abschätzen
also in meiner Karriere als
Kapellmeister habe ich seit Beginn
meiner Funktion
bei der Militärkapellmeister prüferclub
494 3500 die regate gemacht ich war ein
Tirol und dann in Burgenland und auch im
Vorarlberg und die gesamtansatzzahl
Einsatzzahl diese Musik sind mir knapp
370 also wir spielen permanent und hier
möchte ich ein herzliches Dankeschön an
meine Frau Bundesministerin sagen
Magister dankeschön für deine Mühen
ehrliches danke schön
danke schön
nicht umsonst sagt man die Frau Minister
gibt den Toten Anne
wir gehen weiter mit Johann Strauß meine
Damen und Herren bei uns saus das hat
Strauß anlässlich der Weltausstellung
1873 komponiert und sollte damit den
ausländischen Gästen das Leben der
Wienerinnen und Wien ein bisschen näher
bringen ja 150 Jahre später hätte der
Strauß wie man ihn kennt diesen Walzer
eventuell oder was geht genannt damals
ist es eben anders und es steht auch auf
einem anderen notenplatz auf Strauß
folgt dann gleich noch einmal Robert
stolzen es war mit Frühling in Wien das
sind zum Frühlingskonzert unsere Garde
freuen Sie sich wieder auf unsere
Solistin juliajewski
Johann Strauß und dann Frühling in Wien
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schöne Frau sie sind von dir ich träum
komm ruhig mit in den Prater mit denn
der meidet uns vielleicht den ein und in
alle Herzen
brennt was ich will meine Kinder
[Musik]
wird der Johann und die Marie und wenn
der Jünger Linden
steckt auf Zeit
[Musik]
wurden mit
jasminkt und sofort
fotografiert dann bekommt das
so
die Musik fröhlichen von dir
[Musik]
küsst man sich aus wenn man den Knien
so manchmal
schauselt mit Gott
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank liebe Julia
und noch ein herzliches Dankeschön meine
Damen und Herren an sie hinter mir sie
sind wirklich ein sensationeller
das ist wirklich eine tolle Leistung
[Applaus]
ich überlege mir gerade wie das jetzt
klingen würde wenn man Klangkörper
Gendern würde
klangkörperinnen ich weiß nicht also sie
ist ein großartiger Musikerinnen und
Musiker und ich habe heute schon zwei
mehr Damen gezählt als das letzte Mal
also es ist ein ziemlich toller Anstieg
meine Damen und Herren wir sind ja immer
abhängig davon etwas zu erfahren wenn
irgendwo was passiert in der Welt auf
der Welt und das sind wir heute
ausgeliefert dann Medien da gibt es die
dann gibt es die dann gibt es die die
Quoten bringen es gibt die Schreier aber
wenn man wirklich was wissen will über
etwas Tragisches dann zum Beispiel ist
das immer wieder eine Expertise des
österreichischen Bundesheeres und er der
nächste Härte nicht zu mir bitte ist
Oberst erst seit September der neue
Garde Kommandant und er ist ihnen allen
sicher vom Gesicht aus bekannt den er
ist vor allem durch seine Expertise im
Bereich des Krieges in der Ukraine fast
am Ende der Woche im ORF bitte begrüßen
wir obersten Markus Reisner
[Applaus]
jetzt muss ich sie mir kurz was privat
Fragen in eine von der Fernsehkamera
sitzen im Fernsehstudio der
Bundespräsident war es wie das ist die
Frau Minister weiß das auch aber das
sitzt man dann von bösen Wolf waren sich
nein der ist schon in Ordnung wäre ist
er beistee zu wenig finde ich Wahnsinn
nervös oder haben sie das einfach so
hingenommen wie jetzt einem Flug in
Black Hawk nein das war ich nicht da
Herr Wolf ist ein sehr sehr netter
Interviewpartner und dadurch dass immer
in meiner Sache so sicher war habe ich
mich ja so ganz beruhigt auf diese
Situation eingelassen immer so den
Eindruck gehabt wenn ich das ist das als
Otto Normalverbraucher sagen darf dass
sie gerade das Telefon am Ohr hat man
mit dem amerikanischen Geheimdienst
telefoniert haben das heißt wir sind
wirklich von unserem befreundeten
militärpartnern bestens informiert und
auch vom eigenen
Datenschutz und der eigenen Abwehr nun
wir haben sehr gute Nachrichtendienste
die bringen also natürlich sehr viel
also an lagerbeiträgen aber wir haben
auch sehr gute Analysten in
verschiedenen Bereichen und ich bin ja
nur ein Beispiel von vielen die es gibt
im Bundestag da darf ich sie jetzt um
die viel gespannt und erwartete
expertise
für diese heutige Veranstaltung hier in
der Hofburg bitten ja bei uns gibt es
also Lage eigene absichtsdurchführung
die Lage ist ausgezeichnet und nicht zu
sagen wunderbar warum denn die eigene
Absicht war es auch heute wieder eine
Veranstaltung zu schaffen in der
Tradition der letzten 15 Jahre ja in
eigentlich im kernersonnen von
oberskirchebner der hier in der ersten
Reihe sitzt mein Vorgänger bei der Garde
und die Durchführung ist das immer mehr
angewachsen und wieder hat das
Bundesheer gezeigt dass wir uns wenig
alles machen können und das Gute daran
ist dass es einen guten Zweck dient denn
auch dieses Mal werden wir signifikante
Summe Geld zusammenbringen um das für
einen guten Zweck zu spenden und in den
letzten 15 Jahren waren das bereits eine
viertel Millionen Euro und das ist also
nicht wenig und verdient sich glaube ich
noch einen extra Applaus das glaube ich
ja
ich möchte sie jetzt nicht in eigener
Sache auf die Aktion Moderator
Notaufnahme machen das braucht man nicht
wie viel erwarten wir denn heute oder
wie dürfen wir denn heute bis jetzt
erwarten schon von den Karten Einnahmen
also die Karte und ich denke es wird
sich ein fünfstelliger Betrag sein sehr
gut dann darf ich sie einstweilen wieder
bitten Platz
10 Jahren führen Sie hier das Kommando
und sie machen das unentgeltlich und ich
denke dafür muss man auch einmal
herzlichen Dank sagen oder Ablauf
danke schön
[Musik]
danke
darf ich dazu nur einen Satz sagen ich
habe sehr viele meinem Leben
gesellschaftspolitische Dinge von Hannes
anders gelernt und der hat mir auch
beigebracht und danach lebe ich schon
seit 30 Jahren einen wunderbaren Satz es
ist keine Gnade zu helfen es ist
vielmehr eine Gnade helfen zu können und
dementsprechend verhalte ich mich auch
bitte begrüßen Sie mit dem ihr
zuständler Applaus Doktorin Dorit
salvarine drin sie ist richtig der Name
kann ich Ihnen in die Augen schauen
frei spielen es gibt viele in diesem
Land auch in diesem Land die nicht mit
der Zuckerschnute geboren worden sind es
gibt viele und da trifft es dann immer
die Kinder die fast keine
schweren Konzerne hinter sich stehen
haben die keine wirklichen
Vertreterinnen haben aber sie haben eine
fantastische Idee gehabt um Kindern
welche Art zu helfen was genau macht ihr
frei Spiel für Kinder
ja Freispiel
versucht jetzt zehn Jahren Kinder die
von zu Hause nicht die notwendige
Unterstützung bekommen
zu unterstützen damit sie einen gute
Bildung bekommen und eine gute
Bildungslaufbahn machen können wie wir
das umsetzen wir suchen und vermitteln
Freiwillige die in Horte und Schulen
gehen und dort mit Kindern die eben
nicht diese Unterstützung haben
lernen Lesen Sprechen spielen lachen sie
einfach stärken sie motivieren und ihnen
zu verfolgen zu verhelfen dadurch
erzielen wir sehr gute Erfolge die
Kinder
werden motiviert sie trauen sich sie
lernen und sie haben weitere gute
berufserfolgen für welche konkrete
Projekte werden wir heute sammeln ja
alle erinnern uns wahrscheinlich oder
viele als ich in die Schule kam musste
man eine Masche binden können um
schulreif zu sein oder den Hampelmann
machen ja heute kommen Kinder in die
erste Volksschulklasse die können
teilweise fließend lesen und schreiben
können sei es wunderschön zeichnen und
basteln es gibt aber auch leider sehr
viele Kinder die die Volksschule die in
die Volksschule eintreten und nichts
nicht einmal einen Bleistift mit drei
Finger halten können oder eine Linie
nachziehen können und wir arbeiten ja
viel mit Schulen zusammen und
VolksschullehrerInnen sind auf uns
zugekommen und haben uns das erzählt
dass bereits am ersten Schultag in der
ersten Klasse schon so eine große Schere
ist zwischen den Kindern die von zu
Hause gut gefördert werden und solche
die eben nicht diese Möglichkeit haben
und deswegen haben wir uns haben wir
beschlossen unser bewährtes
dass wir bis jetzt in den Schulen in
Volksschulen und Horten ausgeführt haben
auch in den Kindergarten im Kindergarten
anzubieten das bedeutet dass wir
freiwillige suchen die in Kindergärten
gehen um ganz gezielt mit den Kindern im
letzten Kindergartenjahr
nämlich jede Kinder die von zu Hause die
Förderung nicht haben ganz gezielt in
enger Zusammenarbeit mit der Pädagogin
fördern und sich so schulfit machen und
dafür werden wir die Spenden und die
Einnahmen aus diesen Abend verwenden und
bei der Gelegenheit möchte ich wirklich
allen bedanken die dazu beigetragen
haben vielen herzlichen Dank den Herr
Bundespräsidenten Frau Doris schmidauer
der Frau Minister Penner und der Garde
natürlich
Julia Wischnewski die sich bereit
erklärt hat auf das unentgeltlich für
uns zu wachen und ich hoffe ich habe
jetzt alle erwähnt wenn nicht dann ist
es nicht absichtlich danke danke und wir
brauchen wirklich die Unterstützung
jedes einzelnen
danke schön für Ihre Informationen danke
schön
varani jetzt merken wir es
Frau Dr salvarani jeder hat drei
Versuche
in der Pause fährt das Publikum
entkommen sie uns nicht um eine
militärische Fachbegriff zu machen wir
werden sie in die Zangen nehmen die
verbundungsminister und ich beide mit
einer Spendenbox
in der Hand habend sie kennen das schon
und sie entkommen uns ganz sicher nicht
jeder darf natürlich es muss überhaupt
niemand Spenden jeder darf spenden der
Bundespräsident hat den Glückwunsch dazu
haben nie Geld bei sich haben wir schon
gelernt aber ihre Frau ist ja auch da
also in dem Fall wir wollen jetzt
weitermachen musikalisch ein bisschen
ihnen Zeit zu geben gehen wir doch ein
bisschen in die gute alte Zeit zurück
und die Moldau von Friedrich Smetana ja
das ist unvergleichliche unvergessliche
Eleganz musikalisch und damit hat er
sich auch ein Denkmal gesetzt für mich
wahnsinnig denn diese Stück spielen die
Damen und Herren da gerade Musik extrem
gut das nicht woran das liegt vielleicht
ist es diese wunderbare langsame Fluss
der wollte auch nicht dass du zu langsam
die regierst lieber was nein aber es ist
einfach etwas Einzigartiges nein ich
muss reden bis fünf vor acht hatten also
jetzt bis der Moderator das schnell bist
können sie nicht vorstellen sonst sagen
gib Gas gibt Gas gib Gas jetzt sagt er
bei mir ist nur zwei Minuten bitte sehr
froh dass sie nicht erzähle was heute
alles zu Haus passiert ist ich
hergekommen bin meine Damen und Herren
habe ich schon gewusst dass das ein
toller Nachmittag wird ich steige aus
aus meinem Auto er muss mich auch
bedanken beim oberstnutholz der mich
seit zehn Jahren betreut also der ist
wirklich einzigartig und ist mein
zweites endlich wie das ist wenn man
einen Advent hat wirklich wirklich
ganz komisch an ganz komisch
sie kommen herein nein nein
soll ich fragen ob ich sie reinsetzen
darf nein nein nein nein nein nein
komisch oder fangen Sie jemanden sie
sagte das verstehe ich jetzt nicht sie
hätten wir im Fernsehen aus genau das
ist es ja ich wollte endlich einmal live
sehen ob sie genauso alt ausschauen wie
im Fernsehen
sie lachen aber wissen Sie wie das weh
tut
wenn man sie rasiert hat und nicht
verletzt hat gut meine Damen und Herren
jetzt ist es zwei vor 20 Uhr so steht es
auf meinem Zettel hier ist sie die
Moldau mit einem wunderbaren Orchester
und einem wunderbaren
Dirigenten in einem wunderbaren Saal und
ich glaube es haben zu dürfen in einem
der schönsten Länder in denen man leben
kann nämlich in Österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine
hochgeschätztes Publikum sie wurden
heute Zeuge eines einzigartigen Vorgangs
den es noch nie in der österreichischen
Armee gegeben hat ich habe nämlich
innerhalb von 15 Sekunden einen
oberstleitenden zum oberstaufsteigen
lassen bitte sie haben Entschuldigung
Oberstleutnant
gut ich muss jetzt wirklich das lernen
was sie da alles hat sie wissen worum es
jetzt geht das ist eine Spendenbox da
kann man kann was reinwerfen es ist ganz
einfach es ist nicht machen kommen sie
nicht an uns vorbei ich darf wirklich
sagen nur kurz unterhalten sie sind das
beste Publikum dass wir heute hatten
danke schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke schön
das werde ich mich an eine x-beliebige
Dame wenden
haben sie diesen Marsch erkannt
persönlich das ist mein Marsch und ich
bin so unendlich dankbar Herr
militärmusikchef für dieses großartige
Geschenk dass du mir anlässlich eines
runden Geburtstages gemacht hast oder
ihr mir gemacht habt vielen vielen Dank
Frau Bundesminister bitte bleiben Sie
gleich bei mir
[Applaus]
wir leben heute hier eine der elitärsten
und traditionsreichsten Verbände des
österreichischen Bundesheers die Garde
und sie zeigt auch heute ihr
friedlichstes Gesicht vor Bundesminister
welches Bild sollte denn das
österreichische Bundesheer der
österreichischen Bevölkerung vermitteln
ich glaube genau so ein Bild so eines
wie wir es hier alle spüren
mitten in der Gesellschaft
Vertrauen weckend immer da für die
Menschen im Land
wenn wir die Musik nicht hätten
dann gibt es diese
250.000 Euro liebe Frau Dr für ihre so
großartigen Verein nicht mit dem sie so
viel Gutes tun für Kinder die sind in
Wahrheit ja unsere Zukunft das
Bundesheer ist vielfältig und endlich
Dank nicht zu letztes Jahr am
Bundespräsidenten aber auch all
denjenigen die erkannt haben dass
Sicherheit vielleicht nicht alles ist
aber ohne Sicherheit alles nichts ist
ich glaube man spürt das heute hier und
ein ganz großes Dankeschön eben
einzelnen und jeder einzelnen von ihnen
weil sie haben dazu beigetragen dass wir
helfen können helfen dürfen so wie es
allen gesagt hat
dankbar zu sein in diesem großartigen
Land leben zu dürfen in Sicherheit und
helfen zu dürfen und zu können ich danke
Ihnen allen dafür dankeschön
der Bundesminister wenn wir jetzt was
man muss nicht zahlen immer vorsichtig
sein wenn wir schauen diese 100
Milliarden in Deutschland für die
deutsche Armee wollen das auch geschaut
haben wenn wir in der Relation gehen
werden das 10 Milliarden für Österreich
gewesen für ihre Armee es wurden aber 16
Milliarden das haben wir eigentlich
schon ein bisschen mit der Nase vorne in
jedem Fall und die brauchen wir auch
dringend abgesichert miteinander das
verteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz ein
Dank an alle im Parlament vertretenen
politischen Parteien die dafür gesorgt
haben den Aufbauplan bis zum Jahr 2032
dass unsere großartigen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten das tun können was in der
Verfassung steht die österreichische
Bevölkerung und alle ihre Einrichtungen
auch tatsächlich schützen zu können und
an einem Abend wie diesen eine bitte
vielleicht dann
sie alle wir müssen schon wissen was wir
zu verteidigen haben unsere Werte wir
leben wir gemeinsam das Konzept der
umfassenden Landesverteidigung wieder
jeder und jede von ihnen kann etwas dazu
beitragen
wie diesen wo unsere großartigen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten im Mittelpunkt
stehen sondern tun wir das an jedem
Zeitpunkt an jedem Ort aus irgendwie nur
möglich ist Dankeschön dankeschön
[Applaus]
für das nächste musikalische Stück habe
ich ganz tief in meine Kostümkiste
gegriffen wenn Sie sich fragen warum
ganz in Blau ich habe gewusst dass der
erste große Hit nach der Pause die ganze
Welt ist Himmelblau sein wird deshalb
auch dieses farbzitat von mir alles
andere wäre nicht richtig gewesen Robert
Stolz hat diesen Welthit für weiß das
genau das hinspielt das weiße Rössl und
uraufgeführt weil alle glauben immer das
war der Peter Alexander oder die
waldharte heiß nein nein nein mitnichten
das Licht der Welt hat dieses wunderbare
Lied nämlich
1930 erblickt wir freuen uns jetzt
nochmal auf die fantastische Solistin
unseres abends Julian und die ganze Welt
ist himmelblau
[Applaus]
[Musik]
deine Angesicht
wo wir uns nicht
[Musik]
Blumen für Julia dankeschön
[Applaus]
wir wechseln auf unsere Dirigenten und
da bitte hier zu meinen Auftritts
Applaus den unserer staatswachtmeister
Johann groß wird sie eine Wüsten er dir
regiert heute zum ersten Mal dieses
große Fest der vor seinem großen
illustrien Publikum hier kommt der Mann
der jetzt die regiert hier kommt
stabswachtmeister Johann groß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war die Gardemusik meine Damen und
Herren mit
medikamentura von Ferrer Ferran der
dritte Satz Roma
[Applaus]
liebe Herr groß
gut
das würde ich ich würde auch wenn ich
mich interviewen würde wäre es wirklich
also mir jetzt fantastisch gefallen wie
ein Fachkreisen nennen diese Stück meine
Damen und Herren den nach der Pause auf
Wecker aber es ist friedlich wie lange
haben Sie gebraucht bis es ein studiert
gehabt haben bitte wie lange sie
gebraucht bis es persönlich für sich
einstudiert haben
ein bisschen wer wem gehört dieses
wunderbare Baby Liebe mütterväter
greifen sie sofort in die Hosentasche
das Handy wurde auf draußen am Gang
gefunden ist gelegen wer muss
ein wahnsinnig hübsches Baby Liebe blaue
Augen
gut will keiner haben wunderbar Herr
oberstleitern wir haben ein Handy ein
zweites Gott sie können es dann nachher
unten glaube ich beim Ausgang oder beim
Büro von uns zauberische uns bitte
Entschuldigung
ja jetzt kommt etwas was man nicht
erwarten würde meine Damen und Herren
dann könnte jetzt eine Anmoderation
machen auf sex bomb sie wissen ja Tom
Jones der berühmteste sechs bomb aller
Zeiten wir bieten Ihnen jetzt nicht
sechs Bons soweit haben wir noch nicht
wir bieten Ihnen jetzt bomb ein
fantastisches Stück von einem Schweizer
geschriebenen komponiert als Solisten am
Gerät sind ich nehme an die kommen jetzt
her Florian Christa mentl
Michael
ranitzki Alexander meierl und Stefan
Mauser Applaus für die vier Herren mit
Sachs
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das meine Damen und Herren das saxcom
von Marshall sauer die regiert von
schnapsnachtmeister Johann groß ich
möchte noch einmal sagen Herr groß ist
Militärkapellmeister Aspirant und noch
in der Ausbildung was wird mit ihnen
passieren wenn sie mit der Ausbildung
fertig sind und hier stehen viermal
klären Miller also ich hoffe sie wissen
noch wirklich
ja das ist heute nicht
wahr
wie alt sind sie
wie lange haben Sie gebraucht um bis zu
dieser Fertigkeit zu kommen mittlerweile
elf Jahren
der Wunsch der Eltern oder Ihr
persönlicher
recht ja das reicht es reicht also
meine Mutter hat mich auf jeden Fall
Schlag gebe ich dabei beeinflusst davon
zu lernen aber war auf jeden Fall die
richtige Entscheidung das ist eine
richtige Entscheidung der für deine kurz
Entschuldigung
vor 13 Jahren freiwillige oder Vorbild
oder
freiwillig umvorbild wer war das Vorbild
mein Bruder na gut durch in der Familie
jetzt bin ich gespannt sie werden jetzt
sagen nein meine Familien sind
Bergbauern aus Tirol und ich wollte
revoltieren woher kommen sie ich bin aus
der Steiermark
wann ist es nicht so weit weg meine
Tirol ist nicht schlecht
sie werden sowas spielen
bei der Musikkapelle
schaut cool aus
sind völlig recht wenn man so ein
Instrument spielt schaut das auch für
die jungen Damen sehr gut aus
Saxophon ist auch ein
Lieblingsinstrument dass sie gerne hören
[Musik]
Paula welchen Grad haben sie schon
Dienstgrad
die Herren die weniger Sterne haben als
sie müssen vor ihnen salutieren stimmt
es
das verdient ein riesen Applaus das
zeigt die Garde
super toll danke schön
danke danke Ihnen auch wenn sie jetzt
glauben der Haider quatscht und
quatschen und Quatsch das hatten einen
Grund weil jetzt gerade wenn Umbau ist
auf der Bühne und wir kommen jetzt ich
darf das nicht sagen aber es gibt im in
unserem im Begriff der Kunst und
kulturbombenauftritte
aber jetzt kommen wirklich zwei Bomben
meine Damen und Herren die sie alle
schon kennen es sind Brüder die beide
miteinander ihre Instrumente derartig
beherrschen und die Leute immer wieder
zu Begeisterung stürmen hinführen wir
haben das erlebt in Mörbisch bei der
Aufzeichnung der großen Fernsehshow
heuer das was sensationell bitte
begrüßen sie mit ihnen Zuständen Applaus
mit dem pilles Medley Darko und Daniel
[Applaus]
das ist das schöne wenn man Moderator
Hotel
abhanden gekommen sie erleben jetzt
gerade Moderator in Not
ist kein Schnee Herr Professor
nein
die sind wirklich nicht da
ich könnte Ihnen jetzt ein paar
schnurren aus meinem Leben erzählen
meine Damen und Herren aber es ist ja
wenn man sehr gut ich habe das draußen
gesehen immer erkannt wird
ununterbrochen ist es nicht das ist
wirklich ich bin gestern
vorbei kein Witz echt passiert und höher
wie die zwei streiten das ist ja
das ist ja gut ich komme hier hör dann
der Fendrich
[Musik]
muss sie wahnsinnig enttäuschen ich bin
nicht rein das Fendrich sagte zu mir war
sehr es ist an der überhartinger
[Gelächter]
sind sie schon da
aber
wir machen die Polka
[Musik]
anbringe
wenn Sie jetzt die Burschen Aufstehen in
fünf Minuten sind die Oberst das
Versprechen hier ist die Polka
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist meine Damen und Herren war die
Volker schelakovic übersetzt Jugendliebe
von Alois Baldwin aus Tschechien Liebe
Verb Bundesminister es ist soweit ich
habe gesagt der oberstleitern wird
oberste hat sie gefunden
wir werden dann genau erforschen wo die
Herren waren begrüßen Sie jetzt mit
einem Versuchsjahr zweites Mal wir tun
uns als wäre nie was passiert ja
begrüßen jetzt mit dem Zuständen Applaus
waren jetzt nicht kommt aber dann ist er
aus jetzt kommen sicher von einer Zeiten
hier sind Darko und Daniel Piller
ja
je später der Abend desto früher die
Gäste guten Abend
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich glaube wenn man so spielen kann
hätten sie auch eine Stunde zu spät
kommen können was war denn eigentlich
los habt sie uns nicht gehört na wir
waren ihn da Traum
der Kantine des verstehe ich ja verstehe
ich
es ist es nicht herrlich lassen die
Bundespräsidenten Worten ich liebe unser
Land ich liebe den Oberbefehlshaber es
ist nicht der großartiges Land
irgendwann das stehst du irgendwo
abgesetzt gut ich weiß nicht wo sie
jetzt hinversetzt werden aber was haben
sie für einen dienstgratal auch ich auch
ja wer war zuerst Korporal er oder sie
warum Sie
Daniel ist da sechs Monate später
eingerückt also jetzt gesagt
komisch weil er schneller kooperal
geworden ist oder sehr nett
bist immer der erste jetzt habe ich noch
eine Frage wie viel von dem was wir hier
gehört haben war jetzt improvisiert oder
würden Sie das nächste Mal genauso Note
für Note wieder so spielen ja also die
ganze Stück war improvisiert es war die
Thema von der Antonia von der Paganini
wir haben auch die bekannte Dämmer
gespielt von der bella ciao auch 16
caprisotto und von der Junker die
bekanntesteg nicht nur dass sie beide
extrem sympathisch sind sind sehr
Musiker großartig meine Damen und Herren
die Brüder da konnte Daniel Piller
ja
ich bin in der Pause gefragt worden
ob die junge Dame noch einmal wo singen
wird ich bin sehr froh dass sie singt es
ist eine Zugabe die heute zu diesem
wunderbaren Abend passt sie sind jetzt
Amigos parasiempre für immer Freunde
noch einmal für Sie Julia welchewski
hier
Amigos para sehr
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und wie es ihr Name
Moser Alexander Moser Alexander
der Julio Iglesias des österreichischen
Bundesheeres
war das ein Partner
war das ein Partner aber was für einer
also der hat die großen Töne
ausgeschmissen aber wie und ja wir sind
ja fast gleich groß
deswegen haben wir auch sehr gut
harmoniert glaube ich etwas geht mir
überhaupt nichts anziehen Sie persönlich
befreundet
wir beide wir haben uns gerade
kennengelernt und das hat gleich gut
funktioniert
also alles muss man nicht gleich
verraten aber ja
mein Gott das wird das schöner
Doppelnamen moseriewski
wissen sie was sie mir wirklich sorge
bereitet haben mir alle den ganzen Abend
werden wir mit mir gerettet von meinen
Freunden vom Herd für beschweren haben
wir ununterbrochen gesagt die hast
treffen
sie sich vorher damals
das weiß ich noch nicht schauen wir mal
aber ich kann leider keine Ermäßigungen
bei tresnewski bieten
ja
sie haben das so groß auch toll gemacht
wie das mit der Panne das ist
schnitterfutter du stehst vor 1.500
Leuten vom Bundespräsidenten
ich wünsche Ihnen beiden das was sie
bekommen haben gut vorzuführen ich sage
das jetzt nicht um eifersüchtig zu
wirken na haben Sie ein schönes Leben
miteinander dankeschön
meine Damen und Herren
langsam aber sicher neigt sich der Abend
zu Ende darf ich sie im ersten sondern
möchte ich bei Ihnen bedanken dass sie
so wunderbar mitgemacht haben bei die
können hier noch so gut spielen wenn Sie
nicht wollen oder sie überhaupt keinen
Sinn und alles was heute passiert ist
ist wirklich passiert das war nicht von
einem Auto geschrieben so was kann man
nicht schreiben die Gebrüder Pille die
dann nehmen sie großartig großartig der
Ton gibt es auch Moderatoren
aufmerksam möchte ich sie machen am 25
Mai auf das große militärmusikfestival
in Klagenfurt am 17 Juni den
traditionstag der Garde in der Maria
theresien-kaserne in Wien und am 19
jänner 2024 können wir uns wenn Sie es
wollen wieder hier treffen zum Ball der
Offizieren sie waren ein großartiges
Orchester meine Damen und meine Herren
lieber Professor danke schön es war wie
immer ein großartiges Erlebnis und es
gibt ja Dinge im Leben eines Berufes
oder jedes Menschen wo das keinen Job
oder Beruf ist sondern eine wahre Freude
ist und das ist eine Freude gewesen für
mich wissen Sie was ich mir gerne
wünschen wird
dass wir nächstes Jahr hier sitzen mit
ein paar Freunden aus der Ukraine die
mit uns gemeinsam musizieren und den
Frieden feiern danke schön bis zum
nächsten Mal hier kommt der Schönfeld
Marsch für Sie auf Wiedersehen bis zum
nächsten Mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war es das war das große
Frühlingskonzert meine Damen und Herren
heute hier in der Wiener Hofburg wenn
sie mir noch einen Satz erlauben das
wären sie mir jetzt nicht glauben das
Handy
dass wir gefunden haben ist das Handy
vom Geiger vom Billa der das Handy
draußen
verzweifeltreten also das Leben schreibt
so schöne wollen wir noch eines hören
auf wieder schauen sie waren ein tolles
Publikum bitte Herr Kapellmeister meine
Damen und Herren
[Musik]
[Applaus]